Val Ginsburg: Now I must point out that
whenever and wherever the Nazis occupied the country,
they made a special point of indoctrinating the population
spreading all sorts of vicious rumours
presenting the Jews as Communists, Bolsheviks,
they were presented as vermin to be exterminated.
And it seemed to work.
In fact 80% of the German killing machine
- of the Holocaust killing machine was non-German.
They knew that hunger is demoralising.
It reduces people to animal level.
And that's what they wanted to do.
They wanted to dehumanise us, to demoralise us
and to isolate us completely from the non-Jewish population.
And then they could do away with us.
They told us to wear yellow Stars of David front and back,
to brand us as different from all the other people.
Iby Knill: I personally found that very  - I got very angry about it.
Because I couldn't see why I should be any different to anybody else
Because none of my friends were wearing yellow stars
And I thought I would put them into an awkward situation,
if I stayed in friendships or relationships with them.
We were also taught that on public transport, we weren't allowed to sit down.
In shops we were the last ones to be served. And I just decided
that I wasn't going to use public transport under those circumstances.
I would rather walk to school and use a scarf to cover my yellow star.
So I seemed to spend most of my time queuing up in shops to get food
Because the rule was that people with yellow stars
should be the last ones to be served in shops.
So quite often by the time it became your turn,
there was hardly anything in the food shops nearby.
Also, our business had been what they called aryanised,
that the state took it over and put a non-Jewish person in charge
Although my parents had still to continue to work there.